former president trump is still  suspended from facebook and instagram  today a facebook oversight board decided  to uphold the social network's ban  mr trump was taken off of those  platforms after the july or the january  sixth attack on the u.s capitol  board members did advise facebook though  to revisit the ban in six months  it must either restore mr trump's  account  finding that the period of suspension  has met its purpose  make the suspension permanent or  suspend the account for a determinant  period of time  that independent board agreed former  president trump  violated facebook's rules prohibiting  praising or supporting violence  he also it also cre agreed he created a  dangerous environment by continuing  those claims of election fraud